how does it feel to be the vet man it's
crazy because
i don't think i never i haven't talked
about this yet but it's crazy because
like whenever music like we listen to
music um in practice and even when we're
in the lab lines in the game it'll be
certain songs that come on and i always
ask the guys like you know who this is
maybe like i never heard this song in my
life and it could be like a mary j blige
song or something you know what i mean
it'd be like it could be a song from
2005 and they have no clue like i was
just born yeah he like and it's like man
i was born in 2001 and it's like oh my
god like but at the same time
you know it's enjoyable because
you learn so much from them and they
teach you so much in in the same token
and
and once you like
accept that it's fun you know i think
one of the guys one day in practice was
like man you're the only person on the
team born in the 80s what does it feel
like and i'm like
i'm born in 89 i'm only 32. like you
know but it's it's
it's just crazy you know to have that
back and forth and this is we we make we
have fun with it so it's definitely cool
just to
just to have that because i learned so
much from those guys as well yeah about
bored in the 80s 89.
crazy and what music they trying to put
you on like nba young boys everything
you name it it'd be some people but but
even that i i listened to it like man
what's who hot right now i listened to
it just so i could be on the same page
as them as well you know what i mean
like so it'd be cool
so when did you realize you were the vet
was it when they were like 89
yeah i think it was like training camp
it was it was some somewhere around
there i think we was listening to like
50 cent get richer by trying album
and somebody was like yeah i was like
one years old two years old and i was
like i remember buying that cd that was
you know i mean all anybody cared about
yeah yeah like i remember i told i was
like yo i remember going to the store
buying that like you just was and that
was the moment that was my first moment
i was like oh yeah it's going to be a
long it's going to be a long year oh
yeah you got to get them on all that
stuff they probably haven't heard even
like old wayne it's so much so much i
asked him about jay-z that was like yeah
i heard about two three jay-z songs i'm
like
i feel offended
i feel offended yeah oh no my gosh no
then you have some teaching to do okay
i do but that that's in in their credit
they
they listen you know and like whatever
it is not even just music just anything
in general even with movies like i do
the same thing with movies have you seen
this movie this movie and a lot of them
like it was one guy
i'm saying his name patrick williams on
the team
i asked him i made a reference one game
we was playing i made a reference from
300 the movie 300 and he didn't get it i
was like you know what 300 is he said no
i said it's a movie
he said what he said i'm gonna go home
and watch tonight so he went home
watched it called me after the movie
said oh my god the movie was amazing he
got another movie from me you know what
he saw oh that's great what'd you say
like this is sparta yeah yeah
it was crazy it was great but he went to
go watch it and he you know it but
that's great